leute sommer state redet welches
irgendwo ins outfit bekommt die meisten
likes das ist eine frage die sich
wahrscheinlich noch keiner von euch
gestellt hat aber dafür bin ich ja da um
diese frage zu beantworten habe ich
outfits von influenza nachgestellt nicht
eins zu eins aber so im stil von und
falls sie wissen wollt wie ich auf diese
idee gekommen bin eines tages saß ich
vor meinem instagram account und mir ist
aufgefallen
wow aber ich kenn style das einzige was
ich als meinen style bezeichnen würde
wären oberteile die sehr bunt sind und
sehr aufgeregt so wie dieses zum
beispiel was ich eigentlich meine sind
diese bunten hemden und so falls ja mich
schon ein bisschen verfolgt und wenn ich
auf meine influenza kollegin schaue dann
sehe ich da auf jeden fall ist also was
werde ich tun ich werde fünf tage lang
diese influenza outfits auf instagram
posten also jeden tag ein bild und das
bringt mit den meisten likes hat
gewonnen aber am besten wäre es wenn ich
euch jetzt mal die kandidatenvorstellung
zunächst muss ich aber erst mal einen
tipp topp auf dem dann nicht wenn ein
guter influenza folgt mir auf tik tok
dann wird jetzt mal weitergedreht werden
kandidaten nummer eins ist nurman eine
frau die ich seit 34 3 bis 4 wochen
meine freunde nennen kann da ich nur mir
jetzt auch seit knapp vier wochen privat
kenne weiß ich dass ihr style auch
privat sehr extrovertiert ist und es
nicht nur für instagram inszeniert wird
finde sie hat zwei seiten an sich
einerseits ist sie so dieses harte
punkige girl und andererseits und kavai
mädchen einfach so richtig süß ihre
haarfarbe wechselt sie öfter als ich
meine bettwäsche und das macht sie finde
ich so besonders und liebenswert ich
habe mich beim einkaufen von ein paar
sachen inspirieren lassen zum einen von
diesem bild erträgt sie so ein
schulmädchen rock oder hose wissenschaft
schuluniform muster schottenrock
glencheck klassisches englisches caro
mit mehreren nebeneinander liegenden
streifen und dazu so ein schlechtes
oberteil das fand ich sehr gut ich
glaube sie es
als ich auch ganz gerne monochrom und
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal wie ich
mich davon habe inspirieren lassen ab in
die zauberkugel ich finde die socken
gegen den letzten schliff verleiht wirkt
es auf den ersten moment nicht wiederum
aber sie hat immer so eine handtasche
weise ich noch nicht weiß ob ich sie
bereitet deswegen doch das schild dran
und ich führe schon immer um liebe was
mir ganz wichtig ist es dieser herz
gürtel um dieses cover herauszuholen
dann so ein bisschen dieser clueless
claire und ich habe das gefühl dass ich
für dieses outfit viele likes kriege
dieses monochrome finde ich irgendwie
gerade auch megageil der rock ist ein
bisschen kurz aber man muss sich auch
mal was trauen und ansonsten würde ich
diesem outfit
acht von zehn geben aber machen wir
weiter mit kandidatin nummer zwei
eigentlich muss man in diesem fall sagen
zu den kandidaten nennen nennen lisa und
lena will bahr die dieser am pläne
hatten schon mit 13 jahren ein besseres
gefühl für fashion und style als ich mit
meinen 25 ihre outfits und meisten
aufeinander abgestimmt weil sie
zwillinge sind tragen sie manchmal
natürlich das gleiche und ich muss sagen
ich kann sie leider nicht
auseinanderhalten sorry die sind einfach
gut angezogen von eine sache dass mir
bei deren style besonders aufgefallen
und zwar haben sie eine sehr große liebe
zu gehen
ich weiß nicht in welchem faymann jeans
oder denim sagt vielleicht wisst ihr
schreibt man die kommentare manchmal die
sich denn im land manchmal lief ich
dienst ich bin dafür wird jeans hemden
jeans komplette outfits jeansjacke mit
jeanshose und noch links schuhe dazu
wenn das nicht eine jeans liebe ist
eindruck hat mich besonders inspiriert
und zwar dieser hier
lena ist komplett in jeans eingekleidet
wird day vor denen ja wohl kommen wir zu
meiner auswahl jeans und weil ich es
ganz oft bei den see fischer hut er muss
jetzt nicht dienst sein ich gehe mal
ganz kurz in die wunderkugel ich war ja
dieses will die liebe zu tun sondern ich
vergessen habe zu sagen ich habe
natürlich die muschel kette die moschee
der die muss sein eigentlich haben die
man weiter so drunter anders kann als
ästhetische befindet
also ich muss sagen diese hosen an ich
versuche euch zu sagen woher ich die
sachen habe ich glaube das letzte
auftritt war komplett von einem outfit
das virus auf und outfitters das hemd
ist von timo wollte er mal weg geben
aber ich wollte es behalten jetzt weiß
ich warum nicht glauben diese machen was
man ein extrem gutes instagram bild ist
outfit ist schon so dafür gemacht dass
man so cool aussehen richtig heißen lisa
und lena menschen inspiration
ich hätte es nicht gedacht aber ich für
diese muschel kette extrem nude-look
edith also das ist browserbasiert ich
glaube wir müssen den entfernt sind auch
shops zu weisen bei denen sie einkaufen
ich würde sagen lisa und lena sind so
lieb fragt mich nicht warum und naomi
finde ich es schon so einer bin auch für
das gehirn ich würde sagen kandidatin
nummer drei ist nicht nur eine tolle
influenza sondern auch die schönste
youtube in deutschland
instagram heißt sie kerl doch ich nenne
sie nur hat sie beste freundin mäuse
pups und die liebe meines lebens ok ich
muss aufpassen was über kelly style sage
denn wir hatten unfälle wo ich schon mal
etwas über ihren eyeliner gesagt habe
und das ist nicht gut ausgegangen
aber um es einfach und schmerzlos zu
beschreiben kelis teil ist cool sie sie
ist ein ko sieger die meisten klamotten
die sie an hart selbst im sommer sind
aus einem weichen stoff gemacht
natürlich trägt sie dann auch mal den
ein oder anderen e on rock wenn sie auf
einem event ist aber privat sagt mir
nicht dass ihr dieser frauen nicht brot
schenken wollte und sie durch knuddeln
wollt das ist glaub ich in moskau sie
ist was sie jemals in ihrem leben an
hatte und das auf einem event ehrlich
gesagt fällt mir jetzt auch nichts mehr
ein ich kenn dich style beschreiben soll
denn ich kenne sie und ihren style
besser als meine eigenen deswegen ab in
die zauberkugel sagt hallo zu lieben wir
das auto oder lieben wir das auf dem
kelly an ich koche gern warum fühle ich
mich in dem auto das durch den aufstieg
machen also die zur rose habe ich schon
eine million mal bei kelly gesehen die
trägt sie gerne dieses oberteil hat auch
einfach kelly geschrieben weil es ist
ein sommerliches oberteil
aber weil nicht auf so einen kuscheligen
und hier natürlich holzfällerhemd das
auch sehr kuschelig ist man darf aber
kellys outfit nicht unterschätzen dass
sie zwar nicht so aufregend aus wie lisa
und lena oder so aber ich meine guckt
euch das an was sind typische depression
scale posen so so was ich mache jetzt
ganz gut meinte klopp weiter wer geheilt
die arbeite seit einer stunde an diesem
tag keine zeit ich auch eine gute
aufnahme dann habe ich den anruf
bekommen an dieser anruf hat die app
abstürzen lassen und stunde an etwas
gearbeitet hat einfach im weg ist
das video hier ich sag mal so kommen wir
zum nächsten auf unsere nächste
kandidaten
das ja nach ghana ist ein sehr frisches
geld jana heute bestimmt nicht wenn tik
tok liliana ist habe ich in meiner
wohnung einen großen fan von ihrem style
und zwar meinen freund tatsächlich habe
ich schon einen style ausgesucht was ich
ihm als jana experte gezeigt habe er
musste lachen und hat gesagt nein das
ist auf keinen fall jahre und deswegen
musste ich noch mal los und nochmal ein
outfit suchen schießt hobbys vintage
schießerei
ich weiß auf jeden fall dass jahre
jünger als ich ist aber was fashion
angeht ist sie mir jahre voraus ihr
outfit war auch das einzige wo ich
explizit nach passenden schuhen gesucht
habe denn sie ist halt einfach immer
komplett vom kopf bis fuß passend
angezogen alles ist abgestimmt alles
passt zueinander und wirkt trotzdem als
ob sie es so schnell zusammen geworfen
hat ich muss ehrlich sein es kann auch
sein dass ich mich kommt er wieder
vergriffen habe und es gar nicht im
style entspricht aber dafür habe ich ihr
outfit komplett bei einem marken design
outlet irgendwas geschockt und wir gehen
jetzt mal in die zauberkugel
[Musik]
aber mit zauberkugel wurde gerade wieder
viel diskutiert ja hast du dein ist
einfach ich krieg sich hin
ich habe auch nie gesagt dass ich mich
mit gefälschen auskenne aber das ist zu
viel
[Musik]
die trägt ja manchmal so einfachen zopf
und janna ist auch drei
konfektionsgrößen dünner als ich
deswegen sieht auch manchmal ein
bisschen mehr model like bayer aus da
sind wir mal ehrlich im laden war
wirklich überzeugt von diesem schuh und
von diesen sachen aufrecht es dazu an
hab ich bin die bunte version von jana
die bunte clown version machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten ok
wahrscheinlich werde ich mich noch
fünfmal um entscheiden unsere letzte
ästhetik nenne ich auch gerne das vero
moda mädchen dann gibt das outfit bei
mir rum oder komplett einkaufen können
und bei branche zu branche so prüße
priori suzuki ist die wunderschöne hat
anna johnson ich muss leider sagen props
an diesen insta feed der ist wirklich
nach farben sortiert sie hat einen sehr
süßen style ich würde sagen es ist so
ich bin jurastudentin und schreibt
gerade im café an meiner bachelorarbeit
und danach gebers kornfeld und
schnüfflern paar blumen ich bin jetzt
sehr froh dass ich dieses autos
präsentieren kann
denn das ist mir einfach gefallen als
das
[Musik]
wir geben uns kaffee den kaffee holen
obwohl ich sagen muss dass ich diesen
rock wirklich liebe und shout out an
vero moda mitarbeiterinnen die waren so
unglaublich nett zu mir das ist so
dieses amt vor blue magic köln luxor
kannst mir nichts anhaben ich habe keine
ecke und kante ich bin einfach ein
nettes mädchen ich finds auch wunderbar
dass ich mir extra clip ohrringe dafür
geholt habt und selbst die machen meine
ohren rot wie kann das sein tipp
irgendwann aufgehört ohrringe zu tragen
weil ich immer davon so rotoren bekommen
habe und hier so kickl
und jetzt selbst mit diesem clip ohrring
stressen dieses managerin ich habe das
gefühl für diesen look bekomme ich viele
like solle einfach so cute ist und ich
meinen anna jones hat auch eine million
follower dh die leute mögen so ein
netzteil und für mich geht jetzt die
woche los ich bin gespannt wer am ende
als sieger heraus kommt wir werden sehen
also ihr jetzt ich dann in den nächsten
tagen absoluter nerven breakdown
eine woche instagram bilder machen und
sie glaubt sich ein fashion star ich
habe es vollbracht ich habe viele tolle
outfits gepostet und ich habe gemerkt
instagram fotos zu machen und alles drum
und dran ist gar nicht so einfach ich
war wirklich eine die gedacht hat ja so
ein instagram account sowohl auf jeden
tag um ein foto von der push back kuren
wirklich leute du brauchst quasi immer
fotografen bei dir muss die immer
gedanken und ein outfit machen ja wohl
gemerkt dass fotos machen auch auf jeden
fall job ist ohne sind gar nicht so
leicht zu posen nicht in jedem von uns
steckt ein model das ist die traurige
wahrheit aber da war doch mal gleich
schauen welcher style gewonnen hat
angefangen die woche mit naomis outfit
damit tatsächlich noch diese kamera
mitgenommen um coole fotos zu machen es
gab tatsächlich auch viele likes 28.500
und 33 weil dieses foto am anfang nicht
so viele likes bekommen hat wollte ich
mal gucken wie dann ein handyfoto
dagegen perform und es tatsächlich auch
28.000 bekommen also es lag tatsächlich
am outfit und ein handyfoto reicht
vollkommen aus elisa und lenas bei war
absolut nicht passend fürs wetter als
ihr euch erinnert es war zwei wochen
extrem war in ganz deutschland aber ich
persönlich muss sagen mir gefällt dieses
foto so unglaublich gut und dieser style
sieht einfach irgendwie so cool aus und
dann hat's einfach nur 18.300 likes
bekommt es hat richtig abgepackt neben
dem anderen am nächsten tag hatte ich
ein outfit pause machen und habe mich im
planschbecken gepostet im bikini 33.000
likes wer hätte das erwartet das nächste
bild hat meine nichte gemacht der kelly
lück auch viel zu warm angezogen ich
musste dieses outfit nur für dieses foto
anziehen und mich sofort wieder
ausziehen weil es wieder 33 grad waren
oder so ich finde aber diese art wird
immer noch sehr gut und es hat 21 1358
leicht bekommen das ist doch gar nicht
mal so schlecht und zudem dadurch
vielleicht kostet schon zu viel auf
instagram also weil ich sonst einmal die
woche was posten jetzt jeden tag was
kommt und die reaktionen darauf immer
weniger wird
aber da kenne ich mich einfach nicht mit
aurich kennen sich einer von euch mit
dem instagram algorithmus aus und kann
mir das mal den kommentaren beantworten
dass jana outfit habe ich einfach ich
hab's vergessen sie auch nicht verpackt
in meinen es ja inspired so jana würde
das nie so anziehen ich fand's gut ich
finde dieses t shirt und die schuhe dazu
und tischtennis es hat alles farblich
zusammengepasst und es hat auch 23.100
like bekommen dieses outfit geht mehr in
richtung vintage als in richtung hip hop
was sie ja doch dann ganz schön
ferdinand einfach das experimentelle
outfit und wenn wir schon mal beim thema
tischtennis sind ich liebe tischtennis
ich habe tischtennis in der letzten
woche für mich entdeckt ich will jetzt
die ganze nur noch tischtennis spielen
so und da sind wir schon beim letzten
outfit angekommen dass andere johnson
outfit mit guten rock süßer hut schöne
kette dazu ein süßer rucksack ich habe
den pulli nicht anziehen können weil
wieder es waren 33 grad und zu keinem
zeitpunkt am tag war es so kühl dass man
nicht in diesem pool gestorben wäre und
es hat nur 21.000 gleich bekommen ich
war schockiert denn ich finde auf jeden
fall das ist super deputy fand auch
lustig dass in den kommentaren ganz oft
stand ich liebe deinen style hab ich mir
gedacht und damit können wir sagen mit
28.500 likes hat gewonnen naomi mañana
experiment hat platz zwei belegt aragon
meine damen und herren auf platz drei
keri auf platz vier
und was die leute gar nicht bei mir
sehen wollen lisa und lena also mir
dieses experiment mega viel spaß gemacht
und mir sind so ein paar sachen klar
geworden währenddessen ich darf schon
öfter mal mir etwas neues kaufen zum
anziehen gibt immer noch eine alte
angewohnheit nie etwas neues für mich zu
kaufen also in dies übertrieben aber
sehr selten weil ich dafür gar keine
kohle hat und meine eltern auch nicht
und als ich dann nach berlin gekommen
hatte ich auch gar nicht und irgendwie
bin ich halt immer noch so gar nicht was
das angeht keine ahnung aber klamotten
sind auch nicht das wichtigste und likes
schon mal gar nicht also das war hier
einfach ein spaß ein bisschen rum gucken
was gut ankommt
aber am ende des tages
es ist ein leih klitsche jemand der so
gemacht hat und das hat nichts mit dem
wert eines menschen zu tun
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen auch wenn
mir das manchmal glauben ein like ist
tatsächlich nur die man dazu gemacht
außerdem hat wie viel mehr likes
bewiesen wieder mental breakdown
es ist so warm schreibt man gerne
wirklich in die kommentare welches
outfit hat die am besten gefallen das
würde mich sehr interessieren findet man
ja nochmal was eine richtung fashion
nicht denke ich kann da auf jeden fall
noch viel lernen eine frage habe ich
noch für die leute die wirklich sich mit
feschen beschäftigen und nennt style
haben wenn ihr einkaufen gehe denkt ihr
an euren style oder ist es dann einfach
nur das was euch gefällt und das nimmt
ihr mit weil so ist es bei mir und dann
wenn ich am ende meine klamotten zu
hause anschauen passt nichts zueinander
weil ich immer einfach nur irgendwas
nehme aber mir keine outfits dabei
vorstellen kann und die leute die halt
so krass gut angezogen sind die wirken
immer so als ob sie ganz genau wüssten
wie etwas aussieht oder wie sie etwas
holen müssen damit sie dieses outfit so
und so machen können vielleicht ist sie
auf dem boden student schreibt immer
gerne eure fashion tipps in die
kommentare
wird das beim nächsten mal wieder einmal
seine musik auf ski aber was fashion
angeht ich bin jetzt echt auch nein sie
strippt gekommen also ich liebe die
neunziger danke tschüss